[Music]
as the Sun rises on a fall morning in 55
BCE cama lays two pigeons on the altar
at the centre of her village she offers
a prayer to Matrona mother goddess of
the earth and lucas chief of the gods
then she brings the birds necks and cuts
them open to examine their entrails for
divine messages
cama is a druid this means she conducts
religious rites but she also serves as a
judge healer and scholar teaching
children and mediating conflict between
Celtic tribes
she began her studies as a child
memorizing the countless details
necessary to perform her many roles
since the Druids knowledge is considered
too sacred to record in writing
like many druids she spent years
studying in Brittany now she is a
resident druid of the vanetti tribe in a
small farming village near the western
coast of Gaul in what is now France
since returning to Gaul
she has received many offers of marriage
but she has decided to devote herself to
her work at least for now this morning
the omens are troubling they tell of war
and strife as they often have in recent
months a neighboring tribe the red Donis
have raided their village and stolen
cattle in broad daylight twice this fall
the children have gathered around to
watch her work
cama plays her lyre and sings to them
she weaves stories of the powerful Kings
who once ruled their land brave warriors
who were slain naked in combat but who
will be reborn as will all the Celts
when the children go off to help in the
fields cama heads across the village to
visit an old woman with an eye infection
on the way to the old woman's Hut she
passes men salting pigs for the winter
food supply and women weaving clothing
from dyed wool she delivers a remedy for
the injured eye it's made from mistletoe
a sacred healing plant but deadly if
used incorrectly from there
cama visits the chieftain to discuss the
omens she convinces him to go and talk
through their problems with their
neighbors accompanied by several
warriors they head through the forest
and demand a meeting outside the red
donas village walls the red ona is
representatives bring their own druid
who cama recognizes from the annual
gathering in central Gulf where head
druids are elected the chieftains
immediately begin to argue and threaten
each other cama steps between the
opposing sides to stop them from
fighting
they must honor her Authority finally
act the Rideau neighs agree to pay
Camus's tried several cattle in spite of
this resolution Gama still feels uneasy
on the long walk home as they approached
the village walls a bright streak shoots
across the sky
another omen but of what back home
Camas it's among the elders for her
evening meal of porridge a bit of meat
and a cup of wine while they were out
during the day an intercepted parchment
arrived
cama recognizes the writing immediately
although the druids are forbidden from
recording their knowledge she and many
other young druids can read Latin from
the message she learns that the Romans
are drawing closer to their lands some
of the elders say that the tribe should
flee to the nearby hills and hide but
cama counsels them to trust in the gods
and remain in their home privately she
has her doubts should the Romans reach
them her power to help might be limited
unlike the other Celtic tribes Roman
legions have no regard for the druids
sacred role as peace mayors before going
to bed she observes the course of the
planets and consults her charts trying
to make sense of the
or she saw earlier the signs are
converging on a larger threat than their
neighbors fast forward over 100 years
into the future and slip into a Roman
teenager's sandals with this video or
rewind time by about 2,000 years and
follow an Egyptian doctor on her daily
rounds
[Music]